okay we should be live
here um plan for today is to continue on
this rocket Landing end oops support
request
okay uh yeah what we're going to do let
me show
this plan for
today I was working on this rocket end
let me just give full context here so
David H retweeted this thing or tweeted
this thing this is an old like
seven-year old environment completely
dated wasn't usable um I got it running
with rendering packages that actually
compile uh I got it into puffer it's
like 100x too slow at least so we're
porting it to C and we're going to see
uh what we can get done on that
today the actual code for it is very
simple the physics engine is a total
pain so that's what we're going to try
to figure out at the
moment oh and then uh also this is the
last day I'm going to be I'm just going
to be doing this yesterday today uh
hopefully we can get pretty far on it
and then the plan is over the weekend
where did this go we had a PhD candidate
who wanted to jump in on this
yeah
so had a little DM thread with this guy
and he'll probably jump in over the
weekend so then hopefully we'll have
this shipped uh this
weekend but my goal for today is to get
it into a sane enough State uh that we
will be able to do that over the
weekend let me show the current version
what I've figured out with it so
far
so this is in the pure C API of the
physics um box 2D thing so I have the
rocket you can see these are the landing
gears here there is physic physical
simulation on them um but mainly the
thing is just the coordinate system is
really weird and I'm having difficulty
figuring out how to like attach joints
at the right places and stuff like
that okay so here are
here are the
and kind of weird that this is not the
right position
right let me
see well hold on this could also there
can be a
rendering error here as well I think
um let me see cuz I'm
giving hold on I give
extent now I give extent correctly
here and
then the thing is that I'm not
rendering there's no like a built-in
render I'm doing my own it's
possible I have this wrong
I think this is getting the
middle of it
right come
two position I actually don't know if
this
is
correct I'm trying to think if I want to
make like a little sample program
um just to make sure I'm doing
RB
correctly is that worth
doing cuz yeah I actually don't know if
this is the rendering or the physics
Sim
uh yeah let me just do that real
what we'll do
is window
that Target
drawing let's start by
rendering like a box of some
variety let's say we're going to do this
at like
testing and
then we
need two
Origin rec.
width and then we
draw rectangle
like
okay we also need to do a
circle at
500 500 I
cool okay so what happened here
um we drew
degrees well first of all I think the
rotation is in
degrees let's do
45° okay yeah so this was in degrees um
but then I think we do have centering
working correctly
because we put this at 5050 and then we
centered it
me and how do we do it up
here
so you get this is the Middle Point
width and
height uh and then this is in radian so
we do float
degrees
for
pi
[Music]
I oh this is what degrees is to ra
was
four so then what we do is we put
degrees in
here let's see if there's anything else
I'm missing
now this looks
good cuz the origin at half yeah this is
the same all right well let's see if
I think today is just going to be like
Focus chill Dev
stream I really would like to get this
thing into a good
do is this already defined by math or
something
I guess it's already
defined okay so
here we now
have this thing
falling and then whatever the heck that
just was
let's see why this would
be why this would be
wrong initial
okay so initial Y is actually puts them
in the
middle it looks
like interestingly so like the legs are
now centered halfway between I'm
definitely not understanding
something
oh yeah okay it's CU it's all from the
center right so it should just
be I think I understand the coordinate
system
now yeah I understand it um okay so we
have the position
okay so this is now uh correct
looking it's still like not perfectly
matched up but it's very
close and that could be the physics yeah
cuz it's changing over time perfect
though
and now we have to figure out the joint
definitions I
believe what happens when I just
uncomment this
actually hold
on why isn't it
um
rotated why don't we see rotation on any
the
degrees okay so here we can see we
have uh some very small rotation in
degrees
degreas this is supposed to be divided
by
go rocket
ship yeah
what is
this leg
away I think I just overtuned this
didn't
right yeah there's the
physics uh now we have to attach these
together we have to figure out the angle
joints we figure out the positions
though what was going wrong there
so now oddly when I attach these things
as
joints they get attached up
here and whatever the heck has happened
is causing this thing
over let's see what happens with this
so when you
attach I wonder if the uh the position
changes contextually based on the fact
that it's
attached what if I just do z0 what
happens
Falls much faster which is interesting
at least
initially yo welcome been a while how's
it
going that's
weird what's up we are landing Rockets
now
apparently I don't know I saw this like
sometimes I just see stuff online I'm
like oh I got to do
that uh and the impetus for this
was where did it
go this rocket sim
here so we got this one working now
we're putting it into
C and the C stuff well the C is easy
honestly it's the freaking physics API
for this it's a pain
there's a lot of cool new stuff I don't
know if you've
seen look at all these
environments applying for grad school
best of luck to
you it's in the US hopefully you've
gotten Gres and stuff underway
I remember when I did my PhD apps I
literally like decided I was going to
apply studied for registered for and
took Gres in the span of like two
weeks grab School of back for you not
really to be honest I'm uh way way
happier doing this stuff now like yeah
I'm going to have some troubles like
with some stuff on business side of
puffer it's going to take a little while
to get uh customers going and stuff
we've had some likelies but overall the
work is way more interesting and uh I'm
in a position where I can kind of just
chill and do this stuff for a
bit
HG I think I dropped
two points on math and perfect
verbal that's nothing to brag about
though like it's it's like a very stupid
test it's like one of those very stupid
tests where it's like you have to the
main thing is just being focused for
that amount of time and not being like
not making careless mistakes it's not
like a hard
honestly I probably wouldn't be able to
do it now though I haven't done any math
in a
while hey how have you been doing it's
been going pretty well Landing some
Rockets waved by a lot of
Unis this probably for the
best it's really a waste of time for um
anybody who has any business applying
anyway is at the top
end we definitely waste way too much of
people's time in their
20s if you're going to waste time in 20s
anyways you may as well be having
fun I would like to understand this
joint DEA thing here I don't understand
how this is influencing the position
system so like here if I
do I'll show uh Ramsey what I'm doing
here but like watch
this so we have this
rocket looks fine right but then if I
attach the joints if I try to attach
those things cuz the the landing gear is
not actually attached as a joint
point then suddenly it jumps to the
middle of the ship like
this you still recommend cs231 it's not
an RL starter it's an ml
starter that's the best starting point
for ML yes
offer would speed up a custom robot RL
that's CPU based
absolutely
and for RL there really isn't
one um there's not like a course I never
took a course in
RL um it's you have to there's a handful
of papers you should probably read and
like a few repositories you should play
around with and then you should just
start like doing stuff for the most
part like when I was getting into when
I'm getting into a new sub field I read
a bunch of papers and I start like I
play around with a bunch of stuff and
then as you get more experience in that
subfield right you read fewer papers and
you do more of your own work cuz you're
confident that you you have a good grasp
of the surface of things that you know
and that you don't and you like you're
not you're usually not wasting time
doing something that's already
I don't understand the positioning of
joints
here I think there's a box 2D thing on
this not
python didn't
see even robotics M
uses Pub
sub
huh that that is a bizarre design for an
what puffer is generally going to be
faster than like your gymnasium sp3
whatever
equivalents like we just have
optimizations that those libraries
don't what are you building
now controlling
Landing rocket orientations
you're controlling The
Landing or
the so it's just the thing is that I'm
trying to Port this rocket environment
that was written seven years ago um by
some random guy uh he wrote it in Python
I'm trying to Port it to C cuz I've got
it working I got his old code working in
Python and it's too slow and the physics
engine he used actually is written in C
so I'm just using the C uh API instead
of the Python one but that's actually
very hard because the python API is very
very different from the C API and the
docs aren't that bad aren't the best but
I'm figuring it
out yeah I don't know exactly what you
asked
there I mean but this type of work is
stuff that people can absolutely just do
like the background for doing this work
is straight
engineering
right like you don't really need to know
much RL to be doing at least what I'm
doing right now yeah to know how
everything fits in in context and how to
optimize stuff for RL sure for what I'm
doing now is just straight
engineering okay so you have body a body
B and
anchor lot of utility functions to
simplify
this
oh
[Music]
so
positive measured in radians
think it makes sense picking up problems
such as these can only truly learn by
building stuff well the thing that's
useful is you need to have a mental
model of like what things are already
solved and what things you know and what
things you don't know that comes from
Reading papers and being familiar with
literature and being familiar with a lot
of the stuff that's out there and how
people are doing stuff you have to have
the big
picture
like my Iceberg video goes through a lot
about how I'm thinking about
reinforcement learning right now and why
I'm doing what I'm doing I have a very
clear picture of why I'm doing what I'm
doing of course like does this specific
rocket EMP need to exist no this
happened because I saw something cool
yesterday and thought okay that would
make a good RL and and maybe some people
will like this
but I do have overall a model of what
I'm doing with
puffer and I'm very confident in
it what is
this local
anchor anchor point is specified in
local
coordinates you can use body utility
functions to simplify
this okay but this
is local
cord orl Advanced a lot since you were
introduced reading papers and so
on that's how you that's what you do in
any scientific field
like yeah that's what you do in any
scientific
field you don't have to go too crazy on
the papers
but you do need to get a grasp
of like the pivotal
pivotal this is very weird how this
works
nothing about puff or
RL like to dive in where does somebody
like that start off well you start off
by like
look here's
po this is the mo this is like the most
widely used algorithm that it solve DOTA
it solves Atari it solves like tons T
and tons of different things right the
whole thing is 325 lines this is not
importing any other
garbage 329 lines rest of the stack
underneath this for like environments
parallel stuff and whatever puffer
currently has that in maybe a couple
thousand
lines like you can literally just read
the code and then there's a paper you
know you can go read the Poo paper you
can do this for like a couple other
things and you're already off to a good
start like literally you can have your
start on the field
today like not next week not in like
over the next three months like you can
literally have that done
today PO is well you should probably
understand where it comes from and
there's a little bit of history to what
got to there but yeah like we're using
po by default in puffer there's more
complicated stuff out there that has
some
application but like a lot of these
things are not very long
right this is true of a lot of things
right if you just don't try like if you
actually look for the simplest possible
way of doing something without all the
fluff like this is true in language
models and such as well like you can
implement Transformers from scratch not
using p torch uh in a couple thousand
lines at
most and people that actually care about
doing that stuff are very good to learn
from right like if you wanted to really
understand uh Transformers and such you
can look at like car pathy's nanog GPT
the only thing that takes much much
longer to like really wrap your head
around
is I think just good programming and
software engineering in general that's
the thing that I don't know away I don't
know of shortcuts in that
space like engineering just feels like
like software engineering it just feels
like a space where you just have to have
been doing it you have to do it for a
very long time you have to make lots and
lots of dumb errors and event you stop
doing things in ways that are completely
dumb or at least you do it less
frequently moving components M's models
agents
actual yes but like the whole stack of
all of that can be a few thousand lines
of
code having no compute
it's not a deal breaker especially with
our new
environments our new ones will run at
like hundreds of thousands of steps per
second even on a
laptop it does help to at least have a
basic desktop set
up this is something I try to help out
with with some of our
contributors like I just got I just
onboarded a new like open source
contributor who made some environments I
said okay you've been doing cool work
we'll get you uh one of these machines
and we'll get you access to one of
these this is going to get built out
over the next year or so as well we're
going to get more of
these really really want to have this
field be in a good spot I'm investing
personally in doing that
don't understand
this
coordinates I don't understand how the
positions of these joints are
passed World pivot
local
anchor
a it takes the same point on
both how long would it take someone to
get
no uh we had somebody joined like two or
three weeks ago it really is more
dependent on your engineering experience
than
anything like you're like the best the
most recent of these is Spencer just
joined like what two three weeks ago
Spencer built these two
environments right I did a little bit of
work optimizing them and getting stuff
nicer for web and now he has got he's
got two environments and a new one that
he's building now uh Nathan built this
pong EnV and is working on a new one
Noah built this breakout en there's this
TCG that's going to need contribution on
really just dependent on enge experience
or how quickly you can learn
there hey
Tim reading up on PO what parts does
puffer take care of for devs everything
but the environment
specifics um it's everything but without
a bunch of layers of abstraction Tim if
that makes sense so like
here's clean puff RL this is our main
train demo script it is like clean RL so
all the implementation details are in
this file you can edit them you can mess
with them there's not like a bunch of
stuff hidden from you but this is also
like in 600 some OD lines one of the
fastest and uh most flexible
implementations out there with tons of
logging and per optimizations
Etc um we have similar stuff at the end
level simulation level
and so on and so
forth open AI said they use po
exclusively they don't really
do like RL in the sense that I think
about it anymore that I know of
um yeah PPO is very nice though it's
just it's a very simple algorithm that
works very well and like it works well
enough that
there's there really has not been
compelling evidence for more complex
methods replacing it
and if you have not seen the my uh my
Iceberg
video this is a 20 6 minute video in
which I go through all the different
things of RL and puffer and what I'm
doing doing with it it's on the YouTube
and also on my X
page can you break it down how these
individual components and
models where does puffer come in did you
see my Iceberg video I pretty much do
like the thing you have to realize is
that if you actually build this stuff
with an eye toward Simplicity like all
these different components end up being
a few th000 Total Lines of code it's not
a
lot yeah definitely watch that Iceberg
video um it'll give you a lot of
perspective like what puffer does is
puffer basically polishes all of these
different components up and makes them
play nicely together like if you look at
the algorithm okay our version is
simpler faster and has better logging
right you look at like parallel
simulation our version is simpler faster
more flexible and actually 10 times
faster in some cases right you look at
our environments okay we have first
party environments that are like a
thousand times faster and then we have
bindings for lots of existing M that
aren't a thousand times faster but are
much faster than anywhere else as well
as less aor prone right it's basically
just systematically going through every
single component of the RL ecosystem and
just trying to polish and simplify and
speed
up there are a few researchy type bets
I've made as well like there are a few
things that we're pushing forward more
fundamentally at the same time a lot of
it is about Simplicity and speed of
everything in the RL
ecosystem welcome YouTube
folks good time to mention that all of
this stuff
is available on the GitHub puffer AI
puffer lib it's all free new stuff is in
Dev you want to help me out a ton just
start the repo helps me out a lot
I'm rather confused just looking at this
joint stuff in the
background I think I am too I think
we're going to we are going to
completely revamp this
field
um it's almost guaranteed at this point
it's just it's a lot of work is all and
we could use more people building these
environments and helping on that
side really just takes um good
engineering background more than
anything
like I don't mean like big you know big
systems engineering or anything it's
just like environments are a few hundred
lines of code it's just simple low-level
Dev and occasionally fighting a dumb
physics API like I'm doing
now first need to understand ouro system
offer being an
Optimizer it's not like an Optimizer in
the sense of an algorithm is an
Optimizer but we do a lot of
optimization on all these components
watch the video like I put a lot of
effort into that video um it's like that
is a that's production content
there like I literally made that thing
to link to people when they ask me
this it spent like a good two weeks uh
two weeks like scripting and editing and
like filming that thing for reference
yeah what the heck is wrong with this
thing like I
don't toine
joints is there something at the top
that tells me
and how do they do the position and
the thecode or another
python too many tabs hold on
this start checking out right now read
up on PO yeah it's like you literally
just have to do it is the main thing
it's like best time to start learning
something is yesterday second best time
is
today it's that
simple like literally just doing that
puts you in the top 5% of people like
asking me about like getting an AI or
doing you know stuff in RL it's
literally just like the people that want
to do it do and they just like they put
in the effort to
learn it's so much easier now as well to
learn than it ever used to be like you
want to know how rough it was 10 years
ago trying to learn AI it was not fun
you know you want to know how much
rougher it was probably like 10 years
before that I don't even want to know
what that those people had to put up
with so much easier now
gets initial
X initial
y do these things get
attached hold on I'm
just put it in global
coordinates good luck with physics API
try to catch next stream thanks yes you
around I think maybe What's Happening
Here
is like
I'm looking at this
joint I'm looking at this
leg and this leg is put at initial
are these supposed to be different
points oh wait these are supposed to be
different points
that's what's screwing it
up yeah that's what it is
so the thing I didn't understand I think
I figured it
you have this local
Anchor Point this needs to
be
B2
get local point and then what you just
have to do here is you just have to
figure out where in the real
world um where in the the
world you want the actual point to be
at so if this is
Lander
oops and then this is going to be leg
ID and
then we actually have to figure
out where this is going to be
on uh in the world
which
though no you just need to find one
have to find a point in the
world
like leg
ey leg
works you need to figure
out I think you need to figure out like
precisely mathematically where this
thing goes
so I mean this is probably
like maybe I can find
it float
Lander leg
X going to
X this is going to
be you
take
Lander with over
two so this is going to be leg I times
so this gets us negative or
positive I think that
is literally
it and then we do they have to overlap
though
be initial
y minus Lander height over two
do World
joint
o
two
[Music]
B this is actually
B2 back
okay and we get this
position then this is going to be joint
does unus that's
fine oh okay look something
actually kind of did something
curious to see what
happens oh
look uh something tells me these aren't
attached they're definitely connected in
some
what I don't understand is how
um The Joint
affects the
position I don't understand why setting
the joint anchor affects the position
of uh the things it's attached to
did I guess he probably just did some
math here to figure this
out I was playing with puffer lib on
custom multi-agent and for airplane
collision avoidance cool that seems like
a reasonable use case
stuff really don't understand
why moving the
joint affects the position
tries to satisfy the constraint by
adjusting the
positions so that their respective
attachment points
the point on each body that corresponds
to the
Anchor match the specified anchor
position oh that's
H okay so it is wrong math but it's
it's handling the math in a very weird
and unintuitive
way I see why he did this in local
coordinates
then let me see so he
did negative I
H I don't understand this
anchoring I don't understand this anchor
anchoring I want to understand how the
heck this is
actually
Lander set to
zero local anchor
this is in World coordinates as well
isn't
it unless this is
changed YouTube might be eating your
messages by the way I'm not seeing
anything just figure out how this thing
works
how the several agents are
trained one model for each agent one
model for all the
agents no so the C's the it depends what
you're doing but the most common use
case is that you apply the same model
independently to the observations of
each
agent so what this means is that you're
using all the training data to train one
model but that model is controlling each
agent
independently and it doesn't have any
knowledge it doesn't like know the
internals of what's going on with the
other
agents this is the default in puffer lib
via hidden States each agent has its own
in each agent has its own separate
hidden state
that means
all agents have the same task not
necessarily you can have the same model
doing different tasks at the same time
uh if you do task condition learning I
do that in some of my
work it's very
flexible like for practical purposes you
can kind of ignore the fact that the
model is the same people get too hung up
on that um like every agent could just
as well have its own model it just turns
out that practically that's hard and
slow um it's better to just use all the
data to train one model very
often this physics engine is kicking my
ass
like I don't understand how the
coordinates are being
done how on Earth they're
this okay thanks yeah no
worries I don't understand this
thing um
how this leg
down does
anything unless hold on does he
have
wait what's this rocket look like on my
screen no this is
correct the legs
are legs are attached in a reasonable
way
Lander yeah
exactly but I don't understand how this
map works out because like what's
supposed to be happening here is that
there's an anchor
point I don't even know why he has the
nozzle on there as like a
physical element in the first place
like the legs are kind of janky if you
think about it like the physics SIM for
the legs is kind of just really
janky like you get these wobbly legs
anyways don't you
maybe I should try to do the
um the
thrust I mean he probably let me see how
he has this modeled in the first
place I mean he has this thing modeled
as a point
Mass
L1
L maybe I don't even need to mess with
the joints
like maybe I just need to
apply the
for we should try that CU otherwise like
this joint API is very janky
anyways let's try that
comment this joint
stuff the thing that really matters is
not the joints in this it's the
forces um okay so here's your physics
box thing
right yeah I think this will be easier
so now I have to figure out how he
applies
forces which should
be
oops it go
Force
Point
wake particles and Rocket
part okay so
literally this thing has just been
vastly complicated because the guy used
um he used the physics engine for
particle effects for some C
reason and for joints and
like yeah I think this will
be a bit easier
ID B2
body
apply
force a
d force is going to be
point the world point is going to
be B2 fact
2 uh L
equals
B2 get local point I
believe get World point
get World
point and then this is going to be
somewhere on
here
minus so there should be Lander
height for
two yeah this is
Lander get World point
their WID over
two
then land their height over
two I
complete too few oh yeah we also have to
figure out what this wake parameter
is option to wake up the
body the force is
ignored if the body is not awake this is
true
right it's like
R okay okay unused variable
[Music]
nope you can
provide a world point
is it moving to one
side I think it is moving to one side
when I do
that hold
that okay so something is happening it's
just the units are screwy right
yeah
um I think I broke
it so here comes the rocket Landing
right
huh is it coming
back
yeah okay so it has to be a SL in a
specific Direction
obviously um let's go figure out that
horce
up this is going to be substantially
easier now though it's the joints thing
was just God
awful uh and I don't even think it was
that useful to be
all right
[Music]
angle box
2D simple 2D constraint
solver uh the original was written with
C the original was written with box 2D
python so I just went to box
2dc it looks like a fairly large and
well-maintained
project it's been used for rlms for a
long time as well
in the engine for computation
here okay so I need to
need we're going to do this in the
render mode to start with cuz it's it's
going to be easier uh obviously we'll
split the the logic out
thereafter really like the physics demo
yeah we'll uh we'll get these things
working um the RL portion is not going
to be
hard it's it's frankly just like the
building of this thing that's
obnoxious like the uh the getting the
Sim to be it's not even getting the Sim
to work it's getting the freaking
physics API to
behave okay so here we have uh worldo
got rotation which is going to
be Ender
ID and I'm literally just going to
do uh B
B2 Force
equals this is going to be do I have
math
imported include
this you apply the
force which is going to
be
load Lo
here see if this does anything remotely
reasonable for
look
uh think we need to
have World
point this point p
one we should do like
draw
something can we see our Force line
Maybe
p.x
p.y yo just back from watching vid not
understand everything can I say a lot of
things are clearer it'll get clearer as
you learn a little bit more in RL it's
the type of thing that you're probably
going to have to watch a few times not
like back to back but like you know do
that you watched it that once read a few
papers watch it again again I it should
really make the space a lot clearer like
I spent a lot of time trying to lay that
out
cleanly very weird how this
is oh hold on maybe I need to convert
y try to train an agent simple Atari M
Atari is really slow as the obnoxious
thing um you can use like our fter pong
M or whatever that we've got in Dev um
or you can use just like C Pole or
something even um read a few papers I
just like to start with go read like
dqn uh
po yeah just read like dqn and po those
are like core algorithms and then you'll
get to read more fun stuff after that
up it's also weird to watch an object
falling like
this yeah look at
that try the pong one then will I be
able to run it on my
laptop so running on one CPU core in my
local desktop GPU this thing currently
trains
at 300,000 steps per second 340 we can
probably make it much faster than that
as well yeah this thing crazy
fast I don't know why we're not getting
any stats out of it at the
moment uh that's not good maybe
breakouts
better there we go we do get stats it
just takes a
second yeah let me know if you run into
any trouble with them but uh people in
Discord are very helpful as
well puffer discord.gg
puffer when you run the m and you say
it's your training
at whatever steps does that mean it's
training
perpetually no what it means what it
means is
that well you have to kind of have some
frame rate in mind right so like let's
say that pong runs it doesn't actually
have to run this fast but let's say that
pong runs at 60
FPS all right so we are doing 340,000
340,000 steps per second divide by 60
steps per second it means you're running
the game of pong at 5,000 some odd times
real time and training on that
data that it's playing the game at 5,000
some odd times real time
speed which is very fast for RL in
general but very slow for puffer we
should definitely have that at well I
guess this is on my local desktop and
I'm doing other stuff it should be at
about a million on a better box million
steps per second's pretty damn fast
trying figure out what the hell's wrong
with this
thing oh
I'm actually confused how this is even
drawing at
weird basically atar game runs
at yeah for the most part it's just if
you you can only train as fast as you
can run the environment and our
environments are
fast a lot of the environments out there
are
not which actually doesn't necessarily
have anything to do with the complexity
of the environment it just has to do
with the quality of the code more than
anything well this is doing something no
idea
why is this
not draw entity
this not supposed to have a negative
sign on
thing it looks like it is actually
supposed to
have a negative sign on it
oh wait did I forget got to begin camera
mode that's not very
smart okay now we have
it well I I blew it off the screen
but right so now we can actually see
where we're going to apply force
from currently right there and we can
see that where we're applying force from
not make very much
sense um I expected this to
be the coordinate system just doesn't
work the way I expected it to be
point oh they have
raycasts cool
get let's say
make box how do I
get wait isn't
this world
Point counting for
rotation accounting for rotation
just oh yeah yeah hold
on I might just be off
[Music]
this is weird I still don't understand
the coordinates
I don't understand
why like you start out right and it's in
the right
spot for
oh
wait this is zero
to start
oh I don't know what the hell happened
there that's
then we
do
radians
alss
float
of oh point
one
times let's see if this shifts it
now yeah there you go so now you should
get shifted a little
bit and then this starts to freaking
rotate for some reason
well the the forces the force does not
get applied in the right spot uh once it
starts to rotate for some
there's something happening with local
coordinates that I'm not
understanding
rotation which is very weird that it's
rotating that way actually cu
get it's not just getting a point that's
below the center of mass
wait I could also be rendering it
wrong that's an interesting
thought maybe this is right and the
other thing is
wrong
right let's think about
that I think they had some weird
coordinate
super difficult
per bio in for
mathematician this is difficult for
everybody because it's just a janky API
that's not well documented
I'm suspecting that I might not be
rendering
the angle the way I think I am
I'm like almost just tempted to make
like a sample toy project with this in
order to
um to make sure I'm actually doing it
correctly
like you just can't tell what the
hell is going on in the
Sim
uh let me see
where let me see if I can figure out
based on
this like
I'm trying to figure out basically if
there's any consistency with how this is
being applied I just can't figure out
the local coordinate system so like
here
this this needs to be not so high
up okay so now we have a rocket right
and and we're going to like send this
think we just have to flip the
y coordinate right
the flipping of the coordinate system is
really
this
be back
I'm trying to make like a a basically
like a physics toy thing so I can see if
these are in the right
direction this is just like a stupid
amount of like finicking I like actually
hate this
this coordinate system is going to drive
me insane I have to figure out something
about how I can like make the rip
coordinate system just be the
same um
yeah I know but it's just
like I'm going to work on this today and
after that I have a a PhD candidate who
actually wants to help with this
um I didn't expect the physics engine to
just be this cancer
if I can figure out a way to at least
get the rendering lined
up I stop screwing up coordinate
really does not play nicely
with your
coordinates let's see what this does and
like wait why
it this should be
y okay so here this needs to just be
zero
it's the stupid coordinate translations
between the freaking render and the
physics engine that's just driving me
insane
it's all it is wait there's got to just
be some sane way of dealing with this
right
no I can't even do that because it's uh
the line is like has one freaking End in
one coordinate space and one end in
another space what a God awful
mean yeah everything is going to just
just be upside
down and that's probably what's
happening with the Y
offset I just don't know how to solve
that because like
happens nothing I can't see anything
because it's
the coordinates are freaking
happens how do I get the mouse position
in freaking world space
on okay I was just being stupid fair
enough
yeah and then the angle doesn't get
messed up because uh it's applied to the
center
right okay so now what if we
do what if we do this now let's figure
out the second portion of this
yeah I've just been working on this for
a long time and I'm like burning myself
where like you start out in the right
spot here
right pushing this up and then as soon
as it
goes this a little bit
I mean does the way it's behaving make
sense let me
see if I push it over
here that didn't work wait hold
on if I push it from here
no this is
not okay it's not behaving the way I
think it is so I assume it's not
rendering
correctly yeah like the forces backwards
on the X
I actually don't understand how the hell
it's possible the x is
sure let me
think
so what is wrong with just flipping the
Y AIS the way I'm
like so I push it up here
right it looked like I pushed it that
way
it looks to me like you're pushing it
from the bottom here when that says
you're pushing it from the top
thing the Y literally shouldn't matter
if I'm at a horizontal
right I like do this
this has nothing to do with linear
algebra this has to do yeah it's like
sure you can say it's linear algebra but
if somebody just [ __ ] with your
coordinate system in a way that you
don't
understand this is not like this is not
just me being mad bad at math this is
like the coordinate system being screwed
in a way that makes no
isn't this going to
draw the wrong way
that would do it
right on this do
it what happens
um so what do we have here
this go to the
top what do
I mean the fact is it is mapping to the
correct
chords if you simulate many concurrent
jobs with physics you just speed the up
the time to make them faster
yes how does fast RL work with physics
depend on time yeah you don't you don't
ever F you don't have to simulate
physics in real time there's like
there's no link whatsoever between the
time that the CPU is running at and the
time the real world is running at that's
not a problem literally none of that is
hard none of the physics here is
particularly complicated nothing here
should be remotely hard the only thing
that is obnoxious right now is this
coordinate system with this renderer and
this physics engine making no sense the
RL problem is Trivial the physics
problem is trivial everything is Trivial
this is pure technical
infuriating um what's going on here is
that
in in the
renderer uh down is down is up and up is
down right so when you try to render
[ __ ] you have to do some adjustments to
the coordinates pretty basic right
except at the same time I don't know
what's going on with the renderer
because the render is switching between
not the render the physics engine cuz it
has like multiple different local
coordinate systems and a global
coordinate system where up is up and
down is
down and basically between all of that
we're just
[ __ ] that's what's going on at the
moment
frankly damn I was switch to it yeah but
like
what rewrite in pure C what do you think
we're doing this is rewriting it in pure
C literally what you're looking at
welcome Jake Losing My Mind here
I would switch to it yeah
fair but now I've got a cool PhD
candidate who wants to use this
thing
um and like this is such a stupidly
simple problem to give up on like I
don't I can't express how trivial this
problem is
like I could make this thing 3D if I
wanted to and add a couple other
thrusters and like some wind just to
screw with it and it would still be easy
for RL RL is really
good and puffer is very fast
where is this Force getting
applied apply
Force what coordinate system the forces
get applied in do we know
just talking about this coordinate
system hell yeah well it's
like you're going to get this in
anything because like most of the time
rendering dis ways down and then physics
dis ways up
and like it causes many more problems
right weren't you rendering it properly
yesterday what happened yeah it's fine
in Python if you want to train your
environment at like a few hundred or a
few a couple thousand steps per
second I mean that's just not a useful
simulation like it may as well not
exist like the thing that happened here
and this is is why
like like bad engineering is just so
freaking painstaking like there's this
big Library box 2D right this physics uh
engine it's been around forever and they
have a python binding for it but the
thing is the python API is completely
different from the cap API so it's
incredibly difficult to translate cuz
like nothing remotely matches up across
this actually looks good this is not by
the same author though that I
like I'm not sure I trust
it like that it doesn't make sense if
you think about it right a physics it
shouldn't have to be tied to a render
Library like
that if I can just figure out this one
coordinate thing it shouldn't be that
bad to just get something at least
I don't understand why this Vector gets
out of
sync get World point
on the Lander this
is taking into account
rotation this is the top of the
Lander right so this
is this is the top of Lander bottom of
Lander this is now bottom of Lander
right no hold on
so now we have bottom of
Lander the
[ __ ] oh hold
two no no no no no something is wrong
here
counting for
rotation the center point
sense well this hold on this one makes
sense
because because of the rotation right
orientation
bar Rock's also using
RB I'm going to have this problem anyway
like Lander height over
two cause the red line to point towards
the
bottom left of the bounding box it's not
just the bottom left of the bounding box
it
like it freaking rotates all over the
place
right yeah look you see that's not the
bottom left of the bounding
box I don't know what's happening is the
thing right I don't even know what the
transform is or is wrong I don't know if
the rectangle is dra drawn correctly I
don't know if the like I don't know what
is wrong with it like cuz I there's like
some coordinate Shenanigans it could be
the local coordinate system like there
are too many coordinate systems going on
for me to know what's happen
happening that's some Cur yeah I know
this is actually driving me insane like
I this has been the least fun day I've
had in a month at
least and that includes like you know
four meeting days in 100 degrees
but I really do want puffer to have some
physic Sims and like there aren't any
because people use the freaking python
bindings to these things which is like
it's calling like this little tiny piece
of C code in a loop a million times a
second and wondering why it doesn't work
right
I've been like trying to think if
there's a way to just flip the rayb
coordinate
system I can't think of one
negative negative Lander height over two
should be the top of it right or
actually put space we're at the bottom
of
it and then if we do like
this we're at the top of
it Lander height over
to no wait cuz up is POS this is
actually
correct that is act this part is correct
here and then
it rotating the other way feels like
it's like rotating the other
way
like like the rotation
backwards oh
[ __ ]
yeah
uh I know what it
is that's so obnoxious
that's so incredibly obnoxious holy
uh the problem is that when you flip the
Y AIS you flip rotation that's the
problem that's what it is that's why it
doesn't make any freaking
sense you flip the y- AIS you flip the
rotation okay I've like completely fried
my brain here I'm going to take a couple
minutes I'm going to get myself a cup of
tea I'm going to use a restroom and I'm
going to be
back we cannot deal with this
um I'm trying to think like we're going
to have to find something where we don't
have have to deal with this cuz this is
just so incredibly ridiculous be right
yep I honestly can't even be that mad
it's
like I should have thought of that uh
why does it not hold
on why can I not oh yeah you can push it
it's just difficult to get it in the
right
direction there's your physics engine
freaking rendering working
just it was the
rotation because I flipped the y- axis I
also have to flip the freaking
rotation but like you got to realize I
didn't even know if it like it was yeah
rendering it was not even it's not that
the force was wrong the math was right
the rendering was rotated the wrong
direction it it was just a really hard
to see
symmetry
God that's God awful
this let me go get my tea
um it's I think that was the worst part
of
it now I'm like way more exhausted from
that than I should be to finish the rest
of this but like I hopefully we can get
a reasonable little prototype since I
got that to work I'll be right back and
then we're going to add we're going to
add side thrusters we're going to add
some stuff and we'll get it into an RL
environment and we'll see from
[Music]
okay here's what we're going to do now
so we've
okay this is p
Thruster this is was this is p
engine uh the
rest left
okay so main
Thruster left is going to
be plus Lander
height this
rust this is going to be
key
W ration
okay we've got
this
the we should hopefully be able to
figure this out fairly quickly it's a
90° flip I don't know if it's um I don't
know if it's plus or
so we apply
here and left
let's see what this
does
[Music]
all right we should actually get um a
three degree of
Freedom
rocket control
apparatus out of this
so this sends us
applying hold
on if I just nudge it a little bit this
way that nudges it that
way and then if I nudge
it yeah so they're just
backwards cuz it should be fire the side
Thruster okay so oop you push it that
way
I think that there's still
uh there's still an issue here so like
if I push it this way it's good but then
once it starts to
what happens
here w
w does this thing
um need to be
periodic so it does not need to be in a
specific domain I don't know why I
thought it would
negative yeah there you go that's what
you want right
pin
um it actually doesn't take very much
work from here if I'm thinking about
it I think that there are some there's
some additional mathematics though that
were in the original environment that we
need to Port
let's get an end to end demo with this
though
B2 we don't need
legs Ender ID
do
Lander just do void in
it that most of this
code actually just goes into here
ID we
do uh where is it
Lander barge
ID we can actually do this should be
Lander star
with the body we have position
type Lander ID we keep
this camera 2D
camera let
do we allocate
client we assign camera
Ender yeah this portion is
all all nice and
easy I think that was literally the only
hard part is what we just had to deal
render
do
client let's do
the
okay just have to move this logic around
a little bit it's all
and this needs to get moved
into these need to get
actions uh we're going to make an
allocator as
well
right the unit yeah we're make an
allocator
and then on
step what we get to do
rest we get to just assign a
force
so
float thrust force equal
is
rest
right and then we can just do
like
uh
scale
side
okay
and then we'll just Define these up
top these are not oh these are much
higher than
okay
and now all we have to do is
R look how simple this
is here we have action
thrust and now we just do
last one is uh load
action is it
right I don't know why this thing does
not like to autocomplete in a reasonable
way
yep
and then in the The Binding for this
we can choose whether we want to
discretize it's very funny because you
know they say in this oh you know one of
the reasons we wanted to have this is
for True continuous control but I bet
you can do it just as well discretized
it's not not that heart of a problem
function as for
our render function we're going to just
keep this for a
we'll play with the RL engine depends
how fast it
is be very mad if I do all this and it's
box 2D is still
slow really shouldn't be
I'm pretty sure writing like a slow C
code is illegal or
something just can't be
done yeah let's see what I need to clean
up in
here right is
Undeclared I do declare
oops
[Music]
and there like
um is there
a mess up
rest
scale right
rebuild wait what are we calling
here demo
what happened
here at Lander
yeah this debugging Loop is incredibly
incredibly
easy here is our
environment and when we render
here we
can we can have some
we'll handle that in a second soon as I
fix this scale I think it's one more
it's a
ah I know what it is yeah that's really
easy
rocket uh-oh yeah I'm not Landing a
rocket
what's the
degrees
0° for
transform how does this not have
any B2 body
that just do
in
tick we'll just
do pick is
zero so we can set this on
reset zero then on
step we do
so we add in some RL standard
stuff and now we need to do a reward um
let's see what they gave uh in this
rocket
yeah we got to
do E2 trans
transform B to
we have figured how to get all these
different variables let's see so we
start with position that's not bad
X
Y we
do
velocity
Y and then
how's the musk rocket going well we
actually got some progress on it I'm
currently we have a very
basic thing that has two side thrusters
and a main Thruster we're going to turn
it into an rlm and then we're we're
going to actually fix a bunch of the
math so it's like somewhat reasonably
realistic very loose description of
realistic but we're going to take a look
at some of the
more some of the math that's in here on
that
the main thing is that I hope it's fast
if it's fast everything else is
easy I put um a very very
high premium on
believe do you think they use RL I don't
know maybe
I don't think that the hard part about
Rockets is getting the is that like it's
a hard continuous control problem um as
much as it's just like it's a [ __ ]
rocket and there are a million things
that can go wrong and you don't exactly
get to test it a bunch of times you kind
of have to get it
at for once is indeed rocket
science for once it is indeed a rocket
science yeah but rocket science and
simulation pretty easy because we don't
have to pay
like millions or billions of dollars to
try the thing we can just run
it like
if basically right if like uh if you
could just solve the problem in in like
a fast simulator and then know 100% that
if you solve it in the Sim you're good
in the real world it would be easy right
this stuff is the hard Parts all the
stuff that can go wrong in the real
world send them puffer to get the 1
million
we will catch a we will catch a rocket
with two chopsticks
[Laughter]
[Music]
sense he literally like started open Ai
and now has another AI lab with 100,000
gpus and multiple companies that use Ai
and do AI
research that makes no
sense for
pretty
sure OS level
AI
well yeah there's some stupid stuff
going like there are some stupid things
going on with like a kernel level it's
yeah there's some stupid stuff with that
nobody cares like nobody needs like
nobody wants that stuff
anyways I got that wrong is it the same
no like but Elon funded open a
originally and then they decided to not
be an open source research lab they
decided to be a closed source for profit
lab like you can go read this story like
I mean I spent open AI to be fair was
really freaking cool in 2018 or whatever
when I was
there they still do good work it's just
be nice if they publish more of it
but if they just said yeah we're a
company like we got to make money now
we're burning you know we're burning a
hole in the pocket I'd be like
cool like they're like oh we can't
release it cuz safety is
[ __ ] handful of functions for each
new environment must be
defined no this is me just this is me
just defining random [ __ ] none of this
is
required I'm going to make the binding
right now Tim you'll
see stop getting distracted by silly
things me make sure this actually runs
now we get to stuff that we actually
Define for puffer we
Define the observation
space we Define the action
space uh
reset yeah I'm stop
step theode
this is like actually incredibly easy to
do so here we have our
type def
struct just put this in scyon real
do okay we make these environments
client don't need any this garbage
Pati act towards terminals we also want
truncations this
one and we also would like to
have uh no
Ms okay we have the
client get
logs we're going to want some logs for
this this is a pretty standard little
piece of code that's very easy to Port
over what do you mean land is Rockets
it's a meme we're doing a rocket Landing
environment in reinforcement
learning so we have
a physically simulated Little Rocket
Landing environment and that we're
building and solving with reinforcement
learning yeah exactly Yeah Tim there's a
little binding for
it it's pretty
simple cool cool yeah we're getting
decently close to having something I'd
say as
well can I see
it I'm in the middle of editing it uh
here I'll show you the cool looking
version that we had
before this one will look like this is
too once we Jazz it up a little bit I'm
pretty sure but like so here was this
original that somebody wrote like seven
years ago it's really slow we got it in
Python like rendering kind of uh and now
we're like reporting it to run and see
it'll be way
faster how long you been coding how many
years it depends when you consider
coding
seriously
um anywhere seriously anywhere
from 11
to 15
years single prefix uh Tim it's cuz it's
an old AP compatibility thing the full
observation space is defined for all the
agents at the same time the single is
for one agent so because the environment
is vectorized you have to have both
Huffer tries to make it easy on you
though what's best way to get better
well the best way is to do it and not to
get distracted by
like ignore any like design patterns
object-oriented programming functional
programming like Frameworks ignore all
the noise and write cool stuff in the
simplest way possible
also use use llms to learn the code
don't use llms to think for you for
writing code there other
thing we didn't have that problem
before like just make whatever I want
yeah make like little projects that you
can actually complete at your skill
level in a very reasonable frame of
time do a project you can complete in a
weekend right do do a few of those then
do a project you can complete in a week
or
two you can literally make whatever you
want that's the cool thing and often
times these things end up being really
valuable like it's the only field in the
world where you can just make whatever
the hell you
want
literally there's no other field in the
world where you can just like make
whatever the hell you want without
having to have stupid amounts of resour
es I can just be like yeah I think I'm
going to revolutionize your scientific
field of reinforcement learning and you
can just do that are you in college nope
out of college out of PhD I am newly
minted MIT
PhD graduated this last spring and now
we're doing full-time reinforcement
learning puffer AI is technically a
company I
uh I'm doing full-time reinforcement
learning
development I can technically make
whatever I want though I like it would
probably be a good idea for me to do
stuff that's reasonably in line with
what I'm trying to do with puffer as a
company so that we actually get some
clients I don't just do completely
random
things it's all kind of in the service
of making this Tech stable and solid and
useful for people
yeah these I mean all these Sims are
basically like writing
games
here I made this little strip down MOBA
for reinforcement
learning runs really fast and train
agents on it
by I've used engines before but I'm
usually writing uh I'm usually writing
stuff from scratch for the most
part I've used engine sure but like um a
lot like here this mooba just uses rib
as a renderer and uh like the logic
doesn't have an engine it's just all in
C yeah learning an engine is kind of
different from learning how to program I
will say
um there's a lot of fluff and things
that you may or may not want to be
thinking
about how do you think like a programmer
by programming a
lot you're programming a
lot I mean there are things some things
if you like stick around like people
that know what they're doing that you
can potentially learn faster and save
yourself some mistakes but uh it will
take a long time
regardless like frankly a lot of the AI
stuff I do um took less time to learn
and get very good at than just general
purpose writing good
code okay we got
this we got to add add logs here I
think yeah we got this
Lander
ocean rocket Lander
what are rewards here I haven't defined
him yet they'll get some rewards though
Lander this is when we actually get to
move fast and like fix things quickly
which is the much more enjoyable part
here you know
not a type
identifier
really I guess I got to link some stuff
don't I
dur this better did we get the thing
linked
it's got to be a
uh I just go look at how box 2D itself
does
it well no because they're not going to
have scyon I'm
this what's wrong with the rocket Lander
whoops this is Lander
fields this process could definitely be
simplified at least a little
cannot assign unsigned in that's
fine so this is where we do a little
cheeky discretization just to be uh just
to play around
we do self. actions
of r
obnoxious we'll do the discretized
version First
okay cool now we actually get to the
correct uh the actual
errors I will be right back going to
grab T and then we just have to figure
out how to link uh compile and Link Box
2D correctly with syon and we should be
set on this and they'll we'll be able to
train some
[Music]
okay what is wrong with box
Tod I don't need these on why do I have
these on
[Music]
let me see
so we have the include D here there is
no Library d
2D maybe there is a maybe the library
does have it hold
extension let me see maybe they just
have it
here box
2D box 2D source
files okay
extra compile
args extra
there also this is
C++ which is weird
pix NP get
include box 2D
include
Source
2D build slash source
livebox
2.a that looks correct to
did you finish the MOBA thing we have a
version of
it with some improvements from before
that is
online there will be some more on it for
sure but we have you know the ability to
train some agents and it's pretty
fast lots of uh lots of stuff in there
currently fixing up just a quick like
two-day project this rocket n uh and
just have to figure out how to
bind I don't know even know if this is
it because is this the same
code I don't even know if this is the
same code
so
weird that like
ra slash
include 2D SL
this do I need a uh a different flag or
something for
oh maybe we do need to
do so obnoxious
though trying to think how I want to
deal with that
got to have box
2D build
well do we need to just get rid of
this because this shouldn't be needed
because it's static right
do I need to
do well this should build extensions
what the
heck why is this so
finicky this should just
want I do for
this I
do box
2D include and then this
that doesn't seem to
help source files list
outputting is it not wait it might not
be
from oh do I literally just need to do
C
type
dude this is just disgusting having to
do we need to do
does probably shouldn't have put those
into the struct
I don't know why I did that it's kind of
stupid
indices ra is onedimensional two were
indexed
ah AC
obnoxious let's just take the
opportunity to uh correct a couple of
things
e we'll just
do this will be a float
float and then all we'll do is
self. float
actions is just going to be like
this M's three float 32 we'll pass float
actions instead of actions and then
we'll simply do self.
float float actions and we'll just sync
the buffer manually this
stuff and then we have uh we forgot to
delete some print statements apparently
that and there we go immediately we
already have something
running we can make this much much
faster doing maybe 512
let's do
bat oh
interesting that's
we'll also be able to multiprocess this
presumably maybe that'll get us to have
this and then we need to think of some
Rewards
y probably need to go get like velocity
and stuff
right
angle actually it would be kind of good
to have uh
reward computed
reward because we already have the stuff
we need right here right
okay and then we'll just do n log so
return plus equal reward
now there we go
episode length episode
off
th000 this can be
over 2,000
1200 just putting like we're just
hacking some basic safeguards on to the
end this just is all we're
doing still rewards way too
[Music]
negative we also need to just reset the
reward at the top right
here x position can be over 5K
5K y position can be over 10K I
believe and the
over
least all right cool now we just have to
play
it and debug the rewards a
all right so I here here we have
our
rewards we can see that this reward goes
down right if you
thrust your negative reward goes way
up if you continue to do this
actually confused is to how it gets this
uh bad of a
score because I couldn't figure out how
to get it to have that bad of a
so we have zero or
one for all of
good there you
go probably need to Norm these things
over
500 over 1,200
oh that's too much isn't it wait no 200
some odk yeah we're
good so already the episode length is
insane
wordss okay so we can see see that we
have rewards that
okay we actually did a decent enough
job with this
normalization looks like we probably
should have done his velocity is a
little
else I don't think we ever set terminals
do
we no we don't mess with these which is
fine we don't have
to we would stop getting logs if that
weren't
see
okay one
right well these rewards don't make any
sense here because these don't look like
rewards that are that bad
oh wait are we just not clearing our
nice logs out hold
on I think we're just being stupid
this is like stupid
right can we just do
well just
copied hold
recompile there we go
haha completely arbitrary limit
bypassed no you're not allowed to
allocate more than 128 worlds for no
apparent reason
me
done okay Rocket
Man try this
and uh one through one
decreasing probably just learning rate
is too
high something like that
decreasing hey
Spencer we're Landing Rockets
least now reward gets worse which is
awkward
it let's see if we play it um
we do
better the thing is I'm pretty sure the
default should
be like you should be able to do well
literally just by not pressing anything
until we add the randomizations
okay so here is our rocket Lander
whoops environment you can see the
reward is actually very
reasonable and if I like start pressing
[ __ ] reward goes up I mean uh reward
gets
it seem like it should just be able to
not learn to not do
anything see if there's a reason it
can't
yeah it
should so something is screwy
interesting
why do we need to get fewer logs oh no
that's
learn Lo actions it's got single action
space discrete
Rewards
yeah it should learn this like instantly
so let's see what's
okay literally just training it to not
do anything
learn num
M give it Ops action terminals no
Ms n
we miss
something oh you know
what hold
still not
optimizing that's
oh is it doing
something there it
goes all right learning is not
completely
and we just make it fast and then see if
we can op
we do two
M's two
we should actually keep that
task
boom
200k yeah we can do even faster I
think it's just a matter
of my M's were willing to run
200 we should make sure we can actually
learn with this
compile oh yeah there it
goes how it
we just run a little sweep on
this something like that
shouldn't be hard
right 20 mil like
this I would hope this is enough to
learn to not do
cool I'll be back in a bit in a few and
uh we'll see if it's figured anything
out by then I'll be right
[Music]
here are we
uh oming or
here hello
how's it
uh okay so it actually this thing came
back
um for some reason it seems to not
like to
relaunch we probably need to do a
cleanup function of some
type this one worked
though this one
worked we can probably do way better
let's figure out what
happened I'm assuming we just need to
make a close
function yeah that's probably it we just
need to properly clean up after the
environment between experiments
this
Lander and then we need to
clean
up when you are done with the simulation
you should destroy the world what a line
uh we actually have to call this one
each time don't
do all
right let's see if this does it
sweep they should not
take 20 million time
steps so this is the sanity check to get
something some reasonable enough
hyperparameters that um it can learn to
literally not do
anything and then after this what we're
going to do is we're just going to like
push the rocket a little bit at to start
and uh we're going to see if it can
learn to write
itself and then hopefully I'll be done
for the day after that
just know I join stream now trying to
create a rocket Lander game that's
controlled by AI kind of yeah let me see
if I can find you the something is
really screwy with this it's not
handling uh there some reason it's not
letting me tear down the experiment and
make a new
one uh here let's
see might be a box 2D limitation
actually but what we're trying to do
is I posted it
before so here's this old rocket EnV
that somebody
made uh I'm trying to Port it step by
step I'm trying to Port it to C so it'll
be way
faster I got it working in Python but it
was too slow so we're now trying to do
the same thing in C and it's been
difficult but uh we have like some basic
basic version of it that we can start
with now
and we essentially trying to figure out
how to train some models on it with
puffer basically with puffer the deal is
as soon as you get everything fast and
as soon as your experiment setup is
Right puffer will just do everything for
you so I'm just trying get it to that
swimmingly let me try something real
quick it's
just um
up okay so this should just be like some
gigantic number yeah let's just
do let's just do
this that ought at least let us run some
experiments
box 2D has this really weird thing where
it likes to prevent you from making too
many instances of itself ah U6 Max okay
so that's a little
65 I that should let us do some
experiments at least if this is the
issue I don't know why they would use a
short for this
Library how is that greater than oh
minus one
yeah when training this AI it must know
the
code input controls that a player would
have it's more like player controls yeah
it doesn't know the code or anything it
just sees like it sees how fast it's
moving it sees where it is um it sees
like its rotation and stuff and it gets
rewarded or penalized
based on how it does it's kind of it
just learns by trial and error um more
intelligent than trial and error but
reinforcement
learning we're currently fighting uh to
get this I mean the funny thing with
puffer like the RL Tech I build is like
the URL is actually really
it actually here we'll just
do
65 yeah that'll just work the funny
thing with the RL is that it's like it's
actually very good such that when you
get everything set up reasonably it'll
kind of just automatic Al solve it for
you um the tough part is getting
everything set up
cleanly that didn't used to be the case
it used to be the case that even then
the RL was a nightmare but with puffer
it's very easy now for a lot of
problems Okay cool so we actually got we
got this built now let's see
if let me see if I'm right if that
actually lets us run some experiments
so this is now
running 200,000 some OD steps per second
this is
literally not a thousand it's 100 times
faster than I had it in
Python we'll see if it lets me cleanly
start a new
experiment I'm curious to
see that's what our me call so you will
make normal game puffer will run and
train on top very beginner uh there's a
little bit more that you have to do than
that you can't just get like a game
binary you have to format the data in a
reasonable way you have to define a few
additional things that's a lot of what I
do with puffer is making that process
easy it's not just games either it'll
work with lots of different types of
simulations um so that's what I'm doing
at the moment and yeah it looks like I
fix that bug at least
temporarily so what is it's doing right
now is it's automatically running
several experiments in order to find
good settings for itself to be able to
solve it more quickly and then based on
that I'm going to change I'm going to
make the problem
harder I'm going to like flick the
rocket a little bit so that it uh it has
to actually write
itself and then we'll rerun it and see
how it does
unfortunately I think this is only going
to be able to run
like a few
experiments before it hits that bug
again in uh in box
2D I wonder how hard it would be to like
mod box 2D there
silly maybe this will be good enough for
now so I mean we might have gotten lucky
with this set of parameters might take
us a second to find a better
one but here we have this nice
dashboard can see that we have a few
experiments going
and we will get to see various outcomes
of these experiments with Associated
graphs and it'll just run these for
us in a few minutes we should have
something
reasonable be able to go from
there what's the chance this is
Spam no
box 2D thing can just be restarted for
each run
yeah kind of except that the way that we
do our experiment harness like the way
that these sweeps run you don't get a
fully clean setting every time you run
and like for some reason it's I don't
know what it's doing it's like caching
number of Worlds created or something
weird um it's very
silly it also they just like arbitrarily
limit it so like they wrote this whole
engine and then they have hardcoded
there's a constant in there that says
you can't simulate more than 128 Worlds
at the same
time with puffer we usually we want to
train on thousands at the same
time really you're kind of just trolling
if you're going much
slower okay so here we have episode
return it's very weird how this one
actually
previous one here
can't you run the simulations on
different processes we already have them
on different processes but we're
starting
uh we're starting like 2,000 per process
So eventually it'll catch up I mean this
is just silly like you know I I can
probably just mess with box 2D and like
find and replace that uh that short with
an INT and then we'll be
PR but like literally just while I've
been sitting here I mean we've got all
these experiments that have run I'm
curious actually what this one did cuz
this is kind of funny that like the
first experiment I did looks like it's
solved it's a very basic task it
shouldn't be hard to
interesting guess it came up with some
parameters we'll let it run a little
longer
at least while it's going here um and
we'll see if we get anything interesting
out of
it but I mean this
is I'm running this on my local desktop
not even on one of my good machines
hey
bet I didn't realize I've been live five
and a half
hours we got um we got some stuff been
alive
good like a Little Rock stopping a
tank yeah yeah it's very
silly you should have seen the stuff I
got stuck on earlier today I had like an
absolutely terrible morning debugging
this janky physics and
rendering but we got it to like mostly
do something
reasonable um and now it's just
like matter what's going on with it
no mechazilla arms dude I like
freaking the physics a the physics thing
is obnoxious the physics API is very
obnoxious we literally just have like a
box now but um we do have we have side
thrusters and we have the bottom
Thruster actually working
is episode
return going on episode return
right literally the first experiment
that I'd run had
um Sal
unless there's something totally wrong
with
parameters cuz a lot of these aren't
working
and this is a very basic test this is
literally like
um I mean they just need to learn to not
do anything and like drift slowly to the
ground and not like hit any of the
thrusters and get it off
center this one's very very
easy get much harder after
this got it discretized as well so it
should be very easy
[Laughter]
yeah thanks for the advertising bet it's
uh
all the stuff I'm doing here is free and
open
source you can check it out
here and if you like what you see feed
the puff for a star helps me out a
also some of our M's
online you can play
them this is the most complicated one we
have at the moment on
here this is actually kind of fun that
like I enjoy playing this
thing some of the abilities actually
feel better to use than the ones in like
real
games which I find amusing
tank old Dev and their ra did you
recompile
it could be that you have old rib
folders with the same name that have the
wrong stuff in them because in the
latest it should literally just pull
down all the rib stuff for
you see if you already if you have old
folders that are named like RB if you
have an old folder that's named
ARB that could mess it up
fresh does it make Raab for you like
does it install
yeah it's relatively easy
for if you have like a solid programming
background we have new people that have
never done any AI that have been like
building useful RL environments that run
crazy
fast cuz it's kind of just like
low-level like low-level environment
games or simulation programming for the
most part
what en doesn't
um what M doesn't work with uh with RB
issues
bet Dev should be pretty
easy I mean there could be someu stuff
broken but shouldn't
be I'm also very confused as to why it
can't solve this all of a
sudden should be able to solve this by
now none of them compiled
MOBA that actually is such a fun
mechanic Dash strike is really funny
them well those B those files are named
wrong so I'm assuming those are
old because it should compile it to the
root directory as just like connect uh
Connect 4
files if you recompile the new one it
should run because that error isn't
possible anymore because raid is linked
statically so if it compiles that's not
possible you don't need to run with LD
Library path or anything it's linked
statically
I'm very confused as to why this thing
is not training when it uh it
trained
previously and it should be a very easy
task as
well I mean it is technically getting
better but
like this should be very very
easy wonder if it's possible that the
worlds aren't resetting correctly or
something weird like
I mean these curves are like
suspiciously
similar like why do they all dip like
late in
training they definitely shouldn't have
that same sort of shape
[Music]
but I could take these
pams I could just take these and see if
these do
it let me
it let's just start on this while I'm
waiting